okay Canada I am not saying not to read
one pace all right the point was more
that if you want to catch up in time for
gear 5's anime debut the fastest way is
unequivocally the manga and nobody was
mentioning it that said one piece's
quality is a bit inconsistent at the
moment and by their own admission too a
lot of this stuff was put together 10
years ago when these guys were teenagers
with little understanding of filmmaking
yet random fan art and even manga panels
appear in Fishman Island and some
standard episodes careful tension and
great action is occasionally messed up
or removed because they hadn't yet
learned that the two mediums require
different approaches to pacing and while
you still get excellent extensions like
big mom vs kaido being cut sometimes the
modern edits are actually really good on
the whole absolutely no hate intended
here at all but just keep in mind that
this is a work in progress and until
they finished updating their older edits
to match the high quality of the new
ones best to maybe mix and match to make
sure your experience is still awesome